[Music]
kathy is with us in phoenix hi kathy
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my calls sure
what's up
well i'm not calling for myself my
husband and i are debt-free and have
really just always lived you know uh
by saving money and and and not living
beyond our means i'm calling about my
son um because we constantly have a
battle with him he is 24 years old he's
amazing he is uh
he's worked a full-time job for the last
two years since he graduated
and he also sells tennis shoes on the
side
and
he has saved up about a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars
um
but he does not believe in putting any
of his money into the bank
he
he tells us why would i do that if i
make twenty percent by reinvesting it in
tennis shoes and reselling them
so he's now he makes
sixty thousand dollars a year and he's
made in the last year about sixty
thousand dollars profit from selling
tennis shoes so all that money just goes
right back into tennis shoes and i guess
i'm old school
it's hard for me to understand that he's
not putting some of it away
and not just reinvesting it constantly
in tennis shoes
and he just recently bought a car
and he put down ten thousand and he's
financing twenty thousand and it said a
six percent compounding interest
and i'm i'm telling him no you have the
money pay cash and he's like why would i
do that i'm making twenty percent off
these ten shoes and then my last problem
that we always have with him is he wants
to quit his job and open up a tennis
shoe store
and he's going to have to pay 75 000
down for that
and he has this debt and so
he he convinces me when i talk to him
that
i'm like well i guess i'm just
that's smart that's smart but i listen
to your show all the time
and i'm almost positive that that it
might not be the smartest thing for him
to be doing
can i ask a quick clarifying question
you let off by saying he saved a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars then you
went into all these details and it got
murky for me does he have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars
in cash sitting in a safe he said he
won't put it in the bank i'm confused
no he has about twenty thousand dollars
in cash and he has about a hundred
thousand dollars in ten issues
oh inventory
in inventory so he goes to different
tennis shoe shows and he sells to also
different uh tennessee stores and he
will sell them make twenty percent
and then he will reinvest all that money
uh he lived with us for two years but he
is now on his own okay
all right
so um
number one uh
forget all the tennis shoes and the
money for a second um
the hardest stage of parenting for me
has been when i no longer had control
over my kids because they grew up
i agree a lot a lot of your sentence
structure and the way you told the story
told me that you're struggling with some
of that too
a hundred percent and
i am trying really hard to let him do
his own thing
but it is hard but i also want to get it
it's hard to watch people you love do
something that you think is stupid
right or questionable in judgment or
whatever phrase you want to put on it so
number one thing is um
just uh
papa dave to uh mama kathy
um
you're gonna have to start treating him
like he is the son of one of your
friends
who's 24 and he's like a man and stuff
yes because you're using your mom voice
on him i heard it
and it has no power anymore
i know
if you were talking to the son of your
friend you would use the persuasive
voice and i never heard you use it yet
okay so that's thing one regardless of
what the content of our conversation
from this point forward is that's your
only shot
because this boy is known as a man now
he lives on his own he pays his own
bills he he's he's free he's allowed to
do whatever he wants and he's no he's
not living his life to please his mom
anymore
and it's not his job to either you
wouldn't want him to
that would be known as a mama i know
that'd be a mama's boy
you didn't raise him to be that you
raised him to be a man all right now
then let's go to if i was coaching my
son's friend who was 24 not my own son
how would i talk to him about this okay
you have done an amazing job young man
with this tennis shoe thing you are a
freaking entrepreneurial rock star i'm
so proud of how much money you've made
now what you need to do to go to the
next level if you were to ask me you
might not be asking me but if you were
to ask me as a person who's older and
know something about business i would
say that you have too much tied up in
inventory
if you were coming to one of our entree
leadership courses and i was sitting and
having a cup of coffee with him at the
break
at the edge of the stage i would tell
him you have too much tied up in
inventory you're illiquid and uh you
need to slow down just a little bit
you're making really good money and
you've fooled yourself into thinking
you're a genius you need to slow down
about two three clicks
and no you don't need to open a store
right now you're making bank yeah you
may want to quit your job and do tennis
shoes full-time because you're
apparently very good at it you pay off
this stupid car that was ridiculous and
um then you need to just work your
tennis shoe business and do it out of
the out of the you know how the
apartment or whatever you're doing it
out of now don't go open a brick and
mortar to and lose a bunch of money to
because you've got this thing on the run
it sounds to me like he's got an
entrepreneurial gift but he needs some
business acumen to go with it so to
fine-tune some of his finances so that
he can take this tennis shoe thing to
the next level i hope he does that and
walks away from his job and hope he pays
off his car and i hope he doesn't open a
brick and mortar until he has to later
on because right now he's making bank
and he has no overhead ken yeah kathy i
hope you heard what dave said here
there's a lot of practical stuff but
what dave's genius is on this is that
you are now not telling him what to do
but you are now giving him advice on
what he is already doing what he wants
to do
it's a total shift and i got to tell you
you said twice in this conversation and
i'm a dad and so i'm only speaking from
where i've blown it in this particular
area i kept hearing you say i'm trying
so hard i'm trying so hard i think
that's not just a phrase i think that's
your real emotion coming out i want to
tell you to stop trying and dave just
gave you the new pathway you know what
i'd do i'd send him a link to an article
or two of some hot young entrepreneur
who cash flowed his way to an
unbelievable business give some evidence
of what dave's talking about how cash is
king and how cash eliminates the risk it
sets him up to blow this business up how
brick and mortar is maybe a thing of the
past
things like that that are more like this
is awesome you're doing great i think
what dave just laid out was a pathway
for you to no longer try hard
stop trying
stop stop trying to check some
information some people in his life to
polish this business acumen yeah and
cheer him on when you give him that
because he's this guy's a stud man yeah
he is taking he took air yeah turned it
into tennis shoes yeah he's just young
he just business you know what i do i
buy him a ticket to andre leadership
event i'm not kidding you here i'll tell
you let me send you an entree let's do
that let's give him an entree leadership
you know get him get him to something
he's definitely an entrepreneur he's
definitely got skill and he's got
backbone he's got moxie yeah swagger
yeah i mean this kid man he's he's
amazing yeah he's very impressive so
yeah hang on we'll send you a copy of
entree leadership we'll be cheering
him and you on yeah from the sidelines
and all of us parents who have kids that
grew up
it's a it's a heartbreaking equation
i know it's heartbreaking while they're
still growing dave
man and just mixing a little family
business with it so that doesn't make it
that doesn't make this too interesting